Clan Elders in mandera town meet to
discuss who is at the talks in the
county
Kenya police officers are among at least
12 people killed in the past month
fighters from the armed group al-shabab
based in Somalia are blamed sometimes we
worry because even now there's a
fearing and there's a military movement
in Somalia right now
now they might run and cross the border
and come to us
the attackers often use improvised bombs
as they move further Inland yeah from
the weapon also you see that it's not
that sophisticated during our visit
assailants ambushed a team of Police
Special Forces so make sure the fans
comes on time
the equipment as the hardware they have
helicopters manned with guns and and and
you know cameras so that they do
surveillance it is the local raw
intelligence that is going to help the
Kenyan government be fit anyone who
wants to destabilize us
Kenya shares an almost 900 kilometer
border with Somalia this is the official
border crossing but it has been closed
for 12 years and across there that is
Somalia but we're told we cannot move
any closer because it is not safe
the Border was closed following the
kidnapping of a tourist and many other
attacks in Kenya
the Army deployed troops to Somalia in
2011 to help defeat al-shabab together
with African Union forces the Kenyan
government lost billions of dollars in
Revenue as an important trade route
remained closed
plans for reopening have been delayed
because of continuing security
challenges this is the main the Deputy
Governor of mandera says everything is
under control and so those are Pockets
that now we can focus and zoom on and we
can handle I completely agree that there
are setting pockets
especially on our major roads where now
they target
and largely our security agencies can
map exactly where those guys are
especially in this day and age
and these Elders say they are working
with the government to ensure that
al-shabab Fighters don't find a safe
haven here
Catherine sorry Al Jazeera Bandera
County in northeastern Kenya